as her bear family we have Ray Winston's
Papa Bear Olivia Coleman as Mama Bear
and up-and-comer fantastic actor Samson
KO as baby bear hello honey in this
movie they're a crime family so they go
around stealing
they're quite threatening but really
funny in the same vein
[Music]
and that's what I really love that's
what kind of brought me to wanting to do
it I hold them
Goldie and baby like they're always at
each other's head underneath all of that
you can see that there's love there you
know I don't get so lovely about it at
first when you go in you're like okay
just need to make sure I don't mess it
up Joe and well are just like hey man
just do whatever you want to do and I'm
like oh that's all right let's have a
cold isn't it so no it's really nice to
be able to be free and explore those
characters with them in the room you
don't tell me what to do listen to your
sister baby
my sister